all right please don't let the bot be
Barbara mint mint yellow man mint you
need a mint I had him in deep mint blah
okay I'll live with [ __ ] wah-wah I
believe it's pronounced Wow isn't it -
the theme like why would it wouldn't
barber only be in the Rayman won its
Barbara Rayman character yeah Barbara is
a Rayman character dummy no I never
played rabbits or Rayman okay have you
just been like whenever you're playing a
game you're like I hope not and then you
load up rabbits and you're like oh thank
god and you had no idea that was a ream
and character yeah I thought barber was
just some fictional character they made
up Bruno very nice
Marc what am I gonna do what am I gonna
do it was my only blue what am I gonna
do draw a card man be a bro no come on
why would I ever know haha dude why are
we all skips come on man okay well
that's all right that hurts like a butt
cheek on a stick my dude turbot well all
right back to your is coming back to
your weird-ass insult Bob ass insult I
guess technically yeah blas insult yeah
what now Bobby I ain't got nothing to do
yeah that's what you get gosh diddly
darn it you're so dumb sometimes
Wow listen wha hey that correctly take
some of that
[Music]
I don't remember rabbits I've never had
ones ELISA we played rabbits
it's gotta be a PG thing [ __ ] strange
[Laughter]
alright cool
not my real dad alright cool
alright baby alright I it's my only hey
what it's I had no options you know what
can i what can I do right
alright well I to also have no options
I also what what you got hey wait a
minute
hey whatever no ahead uh I don't really
want to do that one anymore
no balls you want hey wait a minute here
I don't have a five I do this that's a
wise choice that's a wise choice that's
a wise choice seeing why listen that's a
what is that what does that do me not me
not me not me not me oh you know how to
do it game
number one that didn't make sense in
number two I feel uncomfortable oh you
but bottle bottle bottle jar I'm not
gonna pass that over wait what'd you say
I feel like this game just like it
splits your brain in half and you try to
speak out of both sides and what comes
out is nonsense
no that is that's completely yeah think
of a container and you thought of both
bottles jars yeah what to do what that
rabbit doesn't like it when you take
your time what Oh y-yeah because of this
Wade oh well that's not cool
hey wait a minute man hey Mark I've got
this one in the bag I thought those and
I was looking at the note yes I was
looking at the number upside down that
was my blue Bob I feel like you're doing
this intentionally mark I know that you
had greens bro I gave you green and you
didn't do anything
we're talking here you see put me in
these situations Bob where I can't do
anything and I feel like you do it
additionally a crabapple I finally get
to play what listen huh Bob but listen
huh
Bob but listen huh Bob that was good and
that was what you deserved but at the
same time I don't feel like that was a
pretty oh look here mark you want to do
something okay I mean I'll I'll do some
you do some color does he have Wade I'm
not telling you it's a secret
oh no this game as well as you're doing
that was all your fault Wade someone do
a breakdown in the comments just say
exactly how that was Wade's fault
it'll be really simple Thank You aides
me Finn
that's right guess what you sound like
that's you that's what you are that my
voice in your head yes okay like Jimmy
for self okay why it's not better no no
see Hart did you just read shirt the see
Hart I don't think weights reading that
right I don't think period mat to us why
do you like that car I just I drew it
mom I mean if you make it blue well I
like blues a good color blah I will run
thank you that's a weird threat to me I
think that's a good car color Bob I
think you picked well poop green and
it's weird doctor yeah what's your poop
like it like that it has the characters
on it and everything
oh gosh diddly diddly darn it trying to
like something how can I help you
alright listen he help you help me help
you help who help you help me help you
okay I just want not here Marty have the
way yay
all right cool thanks your walk now I
guess we're all in the same team we're
all we're all on the same page there
we're all in this together to defeat the
huns need God's help well I mean what
the [ __ ] straight out of the gate Oh
brutal eyes that even doesn't even
compare wait
all right listen takes it what color you
want Bob I'll pick it what color well I
mean red was fine I don't know I find
red then doesn't work out well for me
but I'll do it for you Bob look I'll
make the sacrifice for boat by hand is
marked so good now he's been good wait I
hate to break it to you it was in my
pants like that BJ man my hand is pretty
dope really hope you aren't putting
these cards in your pants well you don't
know till you hold them do you I mean
I'm not touching them you got no way to
hold them know when to pants on Oh God
[Laughter]
Wade you have so many cards I do that
doesn't work kind of blue
can you guys blue you guys need to make
it blue and I'll make that's not blue
this is blue you silly dingus Oh No Wow
yeah what's that feel like all right
here we go okay keep talking jumping
there we go that's what I'm just do well
if you block a plus-two from hitting
well it doesn't matter what color I put
but does you know bob has
no weights just gonna change it anyway
alright so whatever color II picks is
the color Wade has yeah thank you thank
you okay never [ __ ] mind oh you know
I challenge that [ __ ] you
oh wait oh no well that sucks
mark I just need you to be nice like I
was to you okay I apparently I can't
play this card that I wanted oh never
mind
I appreciate you wait please but I'm
just having so much fun what hurt me so
much of the Dickens all right look what
you started what did I start what are
you start look what are you did what did
I do
look in the mirror sir all I have is a
camera people don't see the power
holy [ __ ] god damn what a terrible
terrible card to have for this exact
[Laughter]
[Music]
and I'm you that's how you made me feel
uh-huh yeah okay that's how I felt
inside you want to know how I feel you
say your mom
so I'm sorry aunt
it's just muted forever all right I did
not steal that hand for Mark originally
I gave that hand to mark originally
that's true that was originally your
hand wait that was my hand at the start
but at the same time I gave Bob a
similar style thing if you will win and
you pass it on but I didn't ask for that
wait sir wait wait listen you that's
Kylie do you be like a writer it's
really toxic of you to give someone a
gift and then laud that over them that's
not cool yeah that's called Christmas no
yeah you better give me two in return
that's called worthless you remember the
episode of the office where Dwight did
people favors and then held that against
them you remember that it's called
Christmas all right you got me there
but I wanted to speak slower or
something you could mark I think we need
to have a meeting oh no Bob don't you
talk to him I was saying I think we need
to have a meeting about Wade all right
cool let's have that meeting you want to
go in like a separate room or something
I'm even I'm not even allowed to
participate in the game anymore uh-oh
that wasn't fair no that was really
unfair actually I don't go yellow why
not oh god it's all a new button hey
Wade urine is the color of the gods okay
you [ __ ] I don't know I don't know what
you meant by that but you know cool I
guess what's a good color for you to
have some fun
oh I mean like a red or a yellow oh I
like red not good if you go after I just
needed it like eight cards ago I would
have been so mad I'm getting rid of my
bad card here so that we you guys want
to worry about anymore it's all gone and
blah is gonna be punished
Bob's good to be punished as long as you
two never play out good I say unless he
has a +4 hit but I don't like the way
you treat blah are you [ __ ] my
pancakes your mammoth dick into my
pancakes I appreciate the compliment
your well really not what we're all
right tiny dick it's so small where is
it can't find it who knows we tried just
playing games over here there's a whole
search and rescue team looking for that
dick and they found nothing
oh dear well that worked out oh wait
like that's not true I feel like you
might have just won the game blue
definitely yellow Oh goddamn it
okay so I'm thinking of that green I
don't remember
I'm thinking that Reds safe bet I mean
that I had another solution to the
problem all right cool never mind
I didn't I didn't blue anyway I
apologize
[Music]
suck my hand boy that's not the phrase
it's a clear blue
[Laughter]
French horse
was the original sepm they're supposed
to be that like a bonus at the end
mrs. what wait how did I not get that as
fast as possible yeah horse I was horse
the whole time I'm sorry two French
[ __ ] go make sure I emphasize the ste
French on the street in the red-light
district and just every window comes
screaming out in the distance feeling
fear grip you're right that and that was
like a hallway it was a French hallway
oh it was my turn too caught up in the
bit you see hi what happened to our
hands we were all so low and now we're
all so high get a meeting somebody you
know what okay oh I don't have that okay
yeah I know on Twitter ooh no said that
nothing stacks but you understand that
we don't control the rules of this game
right chat that literally we have to
obey the rules of the game because it's
a game did you guys see that that you
know came out on Twitter and was like
you only have to draw one card and you
can't stack draw two new
a poll internet was like well you guys
play uno on computers you play it wrong
and I was like we have no control over
that
well we intentionally set the rules to
[ __ ] each at that's the rule setting I
choose every time I blow it up really no
it's fine fine I won't play a beer with
all my French [ __ ]
wait listen I know I know ladies ladies
please line up one at a time I can't
handle all this it is in fact me it is
me but calm down listen I got a girl
listen I got a girlfriend I'm sorry I'm
sorry I got a girlfriend got a
girlfriend yeah I got a girlfriend yeah
you know what maybe you should leave the
sound of footsteps dear was that German
French enough for you what the [ __ ]
you're saved yes die blah
what did wha do to you
don't wings that sound hold on
was that better don't do that stop doing
the thing you're doing you're sweeter
that sounds supposed to be just curious
yeah that's like a read but you take off
the are you just have the you know it's
nice long winded II after that you're
right making guys still making that
reference huh sweet that's the first
thing I thought of
I just didn't want to say anything
because I didn't want to get him down
any road
baba dude you guys know how to get to
the sweetie I just from I don't even
know it's not from anything it's
literally that's not that's not great
one never should have given him house
guards mark had to come see you from
yeah hey whoa guys can we chill out with
this now we can chill oh that kind of
worked out yeah do you just think if
they do like a live-action Simpsons I
could be Homer Simpson animated drop
cards my cards [ __ ] broken oh I'm
just gonna draw cards okay that's fine I
would like okay I'll sit here and just
keep collecting ah thank you thank you
okay I know what color was that was it
was it green greeny merit I wanna do no
I'm just gonna do it
I'm gifting you something wave well I
don't want to get marks hand originally
you know what you're right it was thank
you for being marked good job thanks
we're really on the same wavelength
there man screw that wait gawk come on
Instant Karma you don't know the meaning
of Karma Oh guess who's got more cards
than waiting okay same amount you won't
you listen did you do that just to get
you son of a [ __ ] prick funny I am
going soon my life is now dedicated to
ruin I'll take all of yours that's okay
it's a free-for-all I got it that's like
karate I was that when Mario saw the guy
die and then the monkey yeah like how
weight mutes himself like he died Oh
discord he just goes quiet oh all this
as it should be let's see here let's see
here let's see yeah play good play my
thank you thank you now who's got more
cards good play now who's got four now
who's got more cards wait
that one was laughing at you not with
you I thought we were friends
you thought wrong good play good thank
you
all right good play
thank you thank you it's okay cuz blahs
got my back
don't hurt me you like that bomb didn't
ya
wait I have a - can I just draw + ah
well but you alright so I've got a
problem
mark yeah listen okay good good good
okay well wait now wait I need a favor
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and he gave you well neat
alright so I got another conundrum all
right well you should ask you for help
man I didn't even know this is gonna
it's gonna cause some problems what my
hand was so good what hey but Wow mmm
listen whoa
[Laughter]
why would you want that back why would I
want this listen when when a amateur
chess player is playing against a master
they can't receive the move they're
making because they're so far down the
road but it'd still be red why you'd be
read some more issues okay
wait everything's fine everything's fine
mark
yes I know everything good
it's Bob you wouldn't understand under
my fingertips when you have a large
brain I knew you would never be able to
perceive my moves I am that smart oh god
I forgot a time for this blasting my
ears all right everyone just let's be
filled wha and don't don't
okay wait why'd you make it blue no cuz
I picked a color that was colorful we
are all back up to eight cards yeah oh
god damn it
huh what the [ __ ]
Wow somebody needs to work out they are
Angie for this game but no no listen
listen listen me me me me me why in
god's name when i gift you that okay
jokes over my cool here we go funny joke
good oh boy okay I'm sure Wade will have
to draw some cards oh I'm sure I'm sure
I'm sure
good joke good joke very good
ah-ha no it's my only blue all right
good good good okay
that's how you know oh sweet ever-loving
Jesus why would you keep it that color
you unbelievable that color is fine no
color sucks I feel like that color
fine in your turn I think your color in
general actually wants a waterslide but
hey yes you know what's a good [ __ ]
color I don't believe you also don't
like this color I think it's dumb and ok
well yeah yeah yeah yeah look who's
gonna get punished now my dude I am
taking you to school what a great look
when you're a master a greenway god this
this is the hand of Marcus Marcus seven
decks ahead of us right high cards
apiece
listen I'm in the baby it's ok wait no
no thank you
is there an upper limit on number of
cards you could have over 30 before dear
oh wait a minute
okay there we go listen it's fine any
more [ __ ] sevens hanging around out
there mommy daddy oh sorry
holler look at that color thank you boys
like that color would be skipped oh boy
please go alright B skip Darwin knew me
did it just hand it around the whole
[ __ ] Wow
everywhere what the [ __ ] man
hey what what oh I got swept up in the
foot you problem I don't know why you're
getting someone yeah yeah that was the
worst color you could have ever chosen
hmm
you are an [ __ ] here's what you get
skip it you can you can talk in that
funny stupid voice all you want but it
still makes you a jerk oh yeah
not blue College eating you yeah I kind
of was so I could do this I couldn't
remember what that like wait a minute
challenging computer wha do walk
challenge do the challenge stupid that's
okay Wade still has 15 cards I think
we'll survive I don't know how do you
have 17 cards and have no blue oh there
you go you've had blue buddy it's okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you have to say wait wait
you lucked out Bob yes I do I do I do I
really do
well I don't really have much choice hey
come on now I know everybody likes blue
okay oh it's not a good thing to happen
right before this other thing that's
happened I never had a finger go numb
for like four straight days no finger my
right hand has been tingling for like
four days in the back too long I'm busy
like woken up with a dumb finger dumb
hand from like sleeping on it but more
than you know into the evening of the
same day I guess you're marking have if
you just wanted your hand back man just
admitted because you like me no it's
fine it's fine it's fine I get it first
off Wade you're making some pretty grand
assumptions
dude they're so big you said a brand not
big but they're so grandiose there you
go that's more appropriate but not the
point it could be you know that's an
option thank you that's not good once he
got Wade we get him like that
got him I missed the D that's too bad
I don't want to do that look mark you
deal with this okay no no I'll deal with
this okay tough crowd hey you good hand
right winning hand well I got a
three-letter scream - oh okay well I got
three by threes red I had a three - so
it's okay cool
aha oh dear is it blue to draw the cards
it says next - [ __ ] him haha
the shoes sort of thought it wasn't blue
[Music]
you